تطلق خمسه الاف قذيفه من عيار 155 ملم كل
يوم في اوكرانيا
الاوكرانيون يطلبون الان من حلفائهم ارسال
مليون قذيفه فكيف بالامكان امدادهم بكل
هذه الذخائر
المصنع الفرنسي الوحيد الذي يصنع قذائف من
عيار 155 بالقرب من مدينه بورش تكلفه
القذيفه هنا اربعه الاف يورو حجبت عن
الكاميرا بعض مراحل التصنيع لانها تدخل في
نطاق السريه الدفاعيه في المتوسط يصنعون
اسبوعيا 630 قذيفه وقبل الحرب على
اوكرانيا كانوا يصنعون 400 دخلنا في مرحله
اقتصاد الحرب سوف نضاعف الانتاج وبالتالي
علينا زياده التجهيزات ودوريات العمل قد
تشمل عطله نهايه الاسبوع
ادنى خطا اثناء التصنيع يمكن ان يكون
قاتلا على الجبهه
يجب ان تتمتع القذيفه بتوازن تام
والا فانها ستهتز بعد اطلاقها ويمكن ان
تطيش في جميع الاتجاهات لتسريع الانتاج
لابد من توظيف وتدريب مزيد من الفنيين
ويجب ان يتمتعوا بالصلابه النفسيه نحن
نصنع ذخيره وهي موجهه لاستخدام محدد كلنا
نعرفه بعض الاشخاص غير مهيئين لهذا العمل
حاليا تستورد فرنسا مسحوق الاطلاق من
السويد واعتبار من العام المقبل سيحضر في
جنوب فرنسا لان السلطات تسعى الى انتاج كل
مكونات القذائف على اراضيها تخضع كل قذيفه
لتصوير اشعاعي دقيق للتاكد من سلامتها
وخلوها من اي تشقق وبعد انتهاء التصنيع
تنقل هذه القذائف الى مخازن سريه قبل ان
تسلم للجيش الفرنسي الذي يتكفل بارسالها
الى اوكرانيا